*T'es encore dans le champ sors un tout petit peu*
parfait ! Début d'intro magnifique !
Comment allez-vous ?
Il y a un an et un mois je crois précisément
J'avais fait un test d'intelligence sur mon chien
pour vous prouver qu'il faisait partie de l'ÉLITE de la société
qu'il allait faire l'E-Esa
qu'il allait faire Sciences Po !
Et il avait réussi tout les tests
Qu'est ce qui vous a étonné ?!
[musique triste + pleurs]
Mon chien est bête !
Noooon
Il nous avait déçu, tous...
Tout le monde était... subjugué par la débilité de ce ch... la non intelligence de ce chien.
Qui se lèche et qui s'en fout TOTALEMENT de ce qu'on est en train de faire
Donc si une année d'humain vaut 7 années d'un chien,
Si je me met à youtube,
Une vidéo humaine de 10 minutes en vaudra 70
!!!!!! OMG !!!!!!
On avait ensuite fait la oufrun pour tester son agilité
Et on avait vu qu'il avait un... un grand courage
Aah !
aaah!..
aaah...!
grrrr...!
En fait, l'intelligence d'un chien c'est sa capacité à s'adapter face à différentes situations
Et donc j'ai checké pas mal de tests et de petites épreuves qu'on peut faire à son chien
Je les ai regroupées comme ça j'ai créé mon propre test que vous allez pouvoir faire à votre chien
sauf la seconde partie parceque ça va être de l'agilité
donc il faut acheter des trucs à Décathlon
On est un an après
Natsu a maintenant un an et demi
À l'époque il avait six-sept moi il était jeune,
il avait la fougue, il se laissait un peut trop induire par ses émotions, il était un peu impulsif
tout ça..
Mais aujourd'hui...
Mais aujourd'hui il a grandi,
il a muri,
il est plein de sagesse,
il est à l'écoute, il est attentif et vous allez voir qu'il va passer ce test haut la main !
Parce que mon chien est INTELLIGENT !
[ Nats ! ]
Allez viens, ça commence, viens
viens là, viens
Allez viens, ça commence
la dernière fois souvenez-vous je m'étais fait piéger
j'avais pas pris de friandises assez... appétissante comme on dit
Et du coup
il s'en foutait un peu de répondre aux ordres
aujourd'hui vous savez quoi ?
j'ai sorti du lourd mon pote
ça... C'est un jouet à Natsu
Attends... attends, attends *rires*
oh putain je suis sûr il va tous nous épater il est très réactif
Regardez sa gueule ! Regardez sa gueule !
Oh de la bouffe
Bon première épreuve !
Patte
C'est bien mon chien, ça c'est fait c'est pour vous
Première épreuve :
C''est un point s'il y arrive c'est très simple
Regardez je sors son jouet
100% de réussite
Je ferme les yeux je sais qu'il va y arriver
Regardez bien
Et c'est un point !
C'est un point
Rends moi ça
Deuxième épreuve : Le rapport d'objet
C'est à dire le "va chercher"
Est-ce-que le chien rapporte ce que son maître vient de lui lancer
Ecoutez-moi bien, quand j'envoi un jouet : il va dessus
Quand j'en envoi un autre, il va chercher l'autre
Et il le met avec le premier
Et il fait un petit tas de jouets
Mais un petit tas à une distance de sécurité de moi-même
Pour pas que je puisse atteindre ce petit tas
La preuve :
Vas-y ramène ça Nats !
Vas chercher !
Ramène le ici !
Reviens reviens reviens
Reviens avec !
Vous avez vu ce qu'il s'est passé ?!
Il met cette distance de sécurité pour pas que je ne puisse faire ça :
Putain... Comment je peux faire
Nats va chercher !
Ramènes la, ramènes la
Hop il l'a ramené ! Bravo Natsu !
Un point de plus
C'est bien, patte
C'est bien mon pote, c'est bien
Eh qui t'as dit attends ohh
Alors ! je suis donc à deux points sans triche
ça ça me fais très plaisir
Ok on va tester l'immobilité
Le chien doit rester immobile
hors de la vue du maître : un point
Alors je vais juste lui prendre le jouet sinon c'est trop facile
vous voyez je suis sincère
Hop ça va là-dedans
pas bougé, attends
attends
bravoooo
On a eut un point !
t'es en train de tous les niqués, t'es un monstre
La suite ça va se passer sur la terrasse
parce que j'ai besoin de plus d'espace
Nats viens, viens là
Est-ce-que tu peux expliquer à ces gens pourquoi t'es inactif sur ton compte insta ?
Toi qui a plus de 600k fans Natsu
Vous avez vu comment il traite ses fans ?
Il prends pas exemple sur moi c'est fou
Non laisse la GoPro !
Ecoutez, la raison est extrêmement simple
J'ai perdu les identifiants
J'ai perdu les identifiants d'un compte Instagram qui a plus de 600k abonnés
Et ça fait des mois et je sais pas quoi faire ?!
Allez viens, on sors, allez allons-y
Ah il fait beau ! On va passer à la suite du test
Il attends que je lui dise de sortir pour  sortir
Regardez bien maintenant : sors !
sors !
sors, viens !
Voilààà
La suite des épreuves messieurs-dames
Le rappel : on évalue la capacité du chien à répondre à son maître lorsqu'il l'appelle
Alors on va tester ça maintenant sans nourriture
ok l'animal est repéré, il se situe dans les fougères
à l'autre bout de la terrasse
Natsu !
Viens là, viens ici !
Viens ici mon grand !
ET c'est un point !!
Et c'est un point !
C'est un pooooinnnt
Il répondra plus jamais à aucun ordre à partir de maintenant
Car je lui ai profondement cassé les cou*lles
Les Shiba sont pas mal rancuniers et regardez bah il est où ?!
Vas-y, cherchez Natsu, allez-y
Eh ben c'est une fin de vidéo *rire*
Regarde, viens, Nats !
Hé ! Il était dans les poubelles !
putaaaaain
Ces gens qui sont des gros porcs et qui ne mettent pas ça dans les poubelles
J'ai un chien de gouttière
Bon c'est un sans fautes pour le moment, on est tous d'accord avec ça
La suite au pied : ici on va tester si le chien suis son maître au pied
sans laisse *souffle* allez !
C'est impossible
Le tout, je le rappelle, c'est de le faire sans friandise
Parce que c'est beaucoup trop facile
Nats ! Viens tu me suis ?
Suis moi, suis moi par là ! Viens ici par là
Suis moi Nats, suis moi suis moi, allez tu me suis
Tu me suis, tu me suis ! oh pu..!
Un point de plus pour Natsu
Il est maintenant temps de passer à la dernière épreuve : du dressage
Une épreuve très classique qui s'appelle le debout, assis, couché
S'il réussit les trois, mon chien à 10/10, Ok ?!
Tous les rageux là. Qui ont dit qu'il était bête la dernière fois
Tous les rageux je vous vois
T'es prêt ?
Debout
Assis
Ok, couché
Patte
YESS !
YESS, viens dans mes bras
Viens dans mes bras !
OLALALA mais on montre au monde de quoi nous sommes capable !
Il a un vrai problème psychologique, je le vis bien ne nous en faites pas
10/10 pour tout ce qui est épreuves de dressage
Il me lèche les doigts mais ce n'est pas parce que j'ai donné des friandises entre les prises
Certainement pas
On passe donc maintenant aux épreuves d'agilité
Je rigole déjà, je sais déjà qu'il ne va rien respecter
Le but de cette activité est de réaliser un parcours avec des obstacles
sans réaliser de fautes le plus proprement possible
en effectuant le meilleur temps
Mais bien sûûûûr
Sur le parcours le chien rencontrera plusieurs obstacles
Début du parcours lancé par l'arbitre au coup de sifflet :
Les haies à sauter
Le chien doit sauter par dessus de haies. 3 points par haies sautées du coup
Le maître n'a pas le droit de sauter les haies avant
aaah c'est horrible, en fait y a un truc dans l'éducation, c'est que mon chien galère à faire une action
Il faut que toi tu la fasse
Et en te voyant faire, il va comprendre
Prendre confiance, et va la faire aussi
Si ça se trouve je dis que de la merde
Ensuite nous retrouvons l'épreuve du slalom
Le chien doit effectuer le parcours en slalom : le maître n'a pas le droit de montrer l'exemple
En effectuant le parcours avec lui
Il y aura ensuite l'obstacle du tube
Le chien doit passer dans le tube, lson maître attends à l'arrivé
C'est mort
Et enfin on finira par le cerceau : le chien doit passer dans le cerceau en sautant
5 points s'il réussi !
Puta*n ça paye bien ça il faut qu'il y arrive !
Pour cette épreuve là je vais être obligé de fonctionner à la réponse gustative
Que je n'ai pas utilisé jusqu'à présent, à aucun moment
Mais là je vais être obligé de le faire parce que sinon il le fera vraiment jamais c'est sûr
Et ça ça craint
Allez on y va
Ok Nats, tu as intérêt à me faire honneur
Je te fais une promesse, si tu réussi mon fils
en me faisant honneur, que tu passes chaque petit..
C'est fou ?!
C'est fou ??!
Viens là mon fils
Peut importe le temps que tu mettras, on s'en fiche
Et si tu prends ton courage à deux mains, et que tu réussis à passer chaque obstacle
Je te promets de retrouver tes identifiants Instagram.
Et tu pourras faire tous les placements que tu veux, tu seras un chien roi,
et plus un chien d'égout.
Tu viens, tu viens là ? Viens ici !
Et il passe pas entre les deux plots !
Il va chercher le sifflet !
ça commence si mal… putaain